The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today
what we want to do
is discuss various
approaches that you
might want to take towards
trying to understand
stochastic systems.
In particular, how is it that
we might model or simulate
a stochastic system?
Now, we will kind of continue
our discussion of the master
equation from last time.
Hopefully now you've kind of
thought about it a bit more
in the context of the reading.
And we'll discuss kind of what
it means to be using the master
equation and how to formulate
the master equation for more
complicated situations,
for example, when you have
more than one chemical species.
And then we'll talk about the
idea of this Gillespie method,
which is an exact way to
simulate stochastic systems,
and it's both exact and
computationally tractable as
compared to what you might
call various naive methods.
And the Gillespie
method is really sort of
qualitatively different
from the master equation
because in the master
equation, you're
looking at the evolution of
probability distributions
across the system, whereas
the Gillespie method is really
a way to generate individual
stochastic trajectories.
So if you start with somehow
similar initial conditions,
then you can actually
get-- you can
get, for example, the
probability distributions
from the Gillespie
method by running
many individual trajectories.
But it's kind of
conceptually rather different
because of this notion
of whether you think
about probabilities
or you're thinking
about individual instantiations
of some stochastic trajectory.
So we'll try to make
sense of when you might
want to use one or the other.
And then finally we'll talk
about this Fokker-Planck
approximation, which, as
the reading indicated,
for intermediate ends,
it's useful to make
this kind of continuous
approximation,
and then you can get
a lot of intuition
from your knowledge
about diffusion
on effective
[INAUDIBLE] landscapes.
Are there any questions about
this or administrative things
before we get going?
I just want to remind you
that the midterm is indeed
next Thursday evening, 7-9 PM.
If you have a problem
with that time,
then you should have
emailed [? Sarab. ?]
And if you haven't
emailed him yet,
you should do it right now.
And-- yes.
All right.
So let's think about the master
equation a little bit more.
Now before what we did is we
thought about the simplest
possible case of the
master equation, which
is, if you just have
something being created
at a constant rate and then
being degraded at a rate that's
proportional to the number
of that chemical species.
And I'm going to be using
the nomenclature that's
a little bit closer to what
was in your reading, just
for, hopefully, clarity.
And I think that some of my
choices from last lecture
were maybe unfortunate.
So here, this is, for example,
m would be the number of mRNA,
for example, in the cell.
This is the rate of
creation of the mRNA,
and then the rate of
degradation of the mRNA.
So m is the number of mRNA.
And if we want understand
gene expression,
we might include an
equation for the protein,
so we might have some
p dot, where some Kp.
Now-- oh, sorry.
Again, I always do this.
All right.
So we're going to
have this be an n dot.
So now n is going to be
the number of the protein.
Now this really is kind of
the simplest possible model
that you might write down for
gene expression that includes
the mRNA and the protein.
So there's no
autoregulation of any sort.
It's just that the
mRNA is involved
in increasing the
protein, but then we
have degradation of
the protein as well.
So what we want to
do is kind of try
to understand how to formulate
the master equation here.
But then also, we
want to make sure
that we understand what the
master equation is actually
telling us and how
it might be used.
So first of all, in this
model, I want to know
is there, in principle,
protein bursts?
So before we talked about
the fact that in-- at least
in [? Sunny's ?]
paper that we read--
they could observe
protein bursts,
at least in those
experiments in e Coli.
Question is, should this model
somehow exhibit protein bursts,
and why or why not?
I just want to see
where we are on this.
I think this is
something that, depending
on how you interpret
the question,
you might decide the
answer is yes or no.
But I'm curious-- I think
it's worth discussing
what the implications are here.
And the relevant
part of this is going
to be the discussion
afterwards, so I'd
say don't worry too much about
what you think right now.
But I'm just curious.
This model, does it include,
somehow, protein bursts?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK.
So we got-- I'd say at
least a majority of people
are saying no.
But then some people
are saying yes.
So can somebody
volunteer why or why not?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think the difference
is if we're-- are we using this
in a continuous fashion or are
we using this in a discrete
fashion [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
All right.
So he's answered both possible
sides of the argument.
And the point here
is that if you just
simulate this from
the standpoint--
certainly, for example,
this continuous,
this discrete-- so
if you just simulate
this as a deterministic pair
of differential equations,
then will there be bursts?
No.
Because everything
is well-behaved here.
On the other hand, if we go
and we do a full Gillespie
simulation of this
pair of equations, then
in the proper parameter
regime, we actually
will get protein bursts,
which is, in some ways,
weird, that depending upon
the framework that you're
going to be analyzing
this in, you
can get qualitatively
different behaviors for things.
But there's a sense here that
the deterministic, continuous
evolution of these quantities
would be the average over many
of these stochastic
trajectories,
and the stochastic
ones do have bursts,
but if you average over
many, many of them,
then you end up getting some
well-behaved pair of equations.
So we'll kind of try to make
sense of this more later on.
But I think this just
highlights that you
can get really qualitatively
different behaviors
for the same set of
equations depending
upon what you're looking at.
And these protein bursts can
be dramatic events, right,
where the protein
number pops up by a lot.
So this really,
then, if you look
at the individual
trajectories here,
they would look very
different whether you
were doing kind of a
stochastic treatment
or the deterministic one.
Can somebody remind
us the situation
in which we get protein bursts
in the stochastic model?
In particular, will we always
get these discrete protein
bursts?
Or what determines the
size of a protein burst?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does it have
to do with the lag
time between when the mRNA
is created [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Right.
So there's a lag time between
the time that mRNA is created,
and then the next
thing would be--
AUDIENCE: When the
protein [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: When the protein
is [? totaled-- ?] OK.
So there are multiple
time scales, right?
So after an mRNA is
created, and that's
through this process here--
so now out pops an mRNA--
now there are
multiple time scales.
There's the time scale
for mRNA degradation.
That goes as 1 over gamma m.
There's a time scale
for protein degradation
after a protein is made.
That goes as 1 over gamma p.
But then there's also
a time scale associated
with kind of the rate
of protein production
from each of those mRNAs,
and that's determined by Kp.
So we get big protein
bursts if what?
What determines the size
of these protein bursts?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's always confusing.
We talk about times.
But in particular, we
have protein bursts
in the stochastic situation if
we do a stochastic simulation.
And that's in the
regime if Kp, the rate
of protein synthesis
from the mRNA
is somehow much larger
than this gamma m.
Have I screwed up?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So this is
also-- in the sense
of being different from the
deterministic equations,
we probably also want the total
number of mRNAs [INAUDIBLE].
Is that sort of--
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah, I think that it--
and the question of what
mRNA number you need.
I mean, it depends on what
you mean by protein bursts.
I would say that so
long as this is true,
what that means is that each
mRNA will, indeed, kind of lead
to a burst of proteins being
made, where the burst is,
again, geometrically
distributed with some--
now there's another question,
which is, are those protein
bursts kind of large compared
to the steady state protein
concentration?
And that's going to depend
upon Km and gamma p as well.
Is that--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I guess [INAUDIBLE] which
is, I guess it would also
depend on how big [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right, well-- and
you're saying time resolution
in terms of just measuring--
AUDIENCE: Yeah. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, OK, but right
now we're kind
of imagining that we live
in this perfect world
where we know at
every moment of time
exactly how many of
everything there is.
So in some ways we haven't
really said anything yet
about time resolution.
We're assuming that our time
resolution and our number
resolution is actually perfect.
But still, depending upon
the regime that you're in,
the protein numbers
could look something
like-- so if you look at
the protein number, which
is defined as this n as
a function of time, then
in one regime, you're going
to see where it's kind of low.
You get a big burst and then
it kind of comes down, and then
a big burst, and then it kind
of comes down, and burst,
and it kind of
comes down, right?
So this is in the regime where
you have infrequent mRNAs being
produced, and then large
size bursts from each mRNA.
And then you kind of get
this effective degradation
or dilution of the
protein numbers over time.
And this distribution, if
you take a histogram of it,
is what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I'm imagining that we look at
this for a long period of time.
And then we come over
here and we histogram it.
So now we come over here,
we turn to the left,
we say number has a function
of-- this is number n.
The frequency that we observe,
some number of proteins.
So frequency.
And this is going
to do something.
So what about-- it may not
be a beautiful drawing,
but you're supposed
to know the answer.
I'm trying to review
things for you because I
hear that you have a
big exam coming up,
and I want to make sure that--
Gamma.
It's a gamma, right?
So this is what we
learned earlier.
So this is a gamma distribution.
And you should know what this
gamma distribution looks like.
In particular, there
are these two parameters
that describe this
gamma distribution
as a function of underlying
parameters in the model.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
I don't want to get too much
into this because, well,
on Thursday we spent a
long time talking about it.
Once we get going, we'll
spend another long time
taling about it again.
But you should review your notes
from Thursday before the exam.
So this thing is
gamma distributed.
And if we looked at the mRNA
number as a function of time
and we did a histogram of
that, the mRNA distribution
would be what?
It's poisson.
So it's important to remember
that just because I tell you
that a protein number
is gamma distributed,
that doesn't immediately tell
you exactly what you should
be expecting for the
distribution of, say,
the number of protein
as a function of time.
I mean, there are
many different things
I could plot over here that
would all kind of come down
to a gamma
distribution over here.
So it's important
to kind of keep
in mind the different
representations that you might
want to think about the data.
So what we want to do now is we
want to think a little bit more
about this master equation
in the context of if we're
going to divide it
up into these states.
Now I would say that
any time that you
are asked to write down the
master equation for something--
so now how many equations
will the master equation-- I
say master equation, but there
is really more than one, maybe.
So how many equations will be
involved in the master equation
kind of description
of this model?
Infinitely many.
But there were infinitely
many already when
we had just one, when we just
had the mRNA distribution.
Well, you know, infinite times
infinite is still infinite.
So long as it's a
countably infinite number.
But yeah, but it's
still infinite, always.
All right.
So what we want to do
is divide up the states.
So when somebody asks you for--
the equation's describing how
those probabilities
are going to vary,
really what we're interested in
is some derivative with respect
to time of some probabilities
described by m,n.
We want to know the derivative
with respect to time for all
m,n's.
So that's why there are infinite
number, because m goes in one
direction, n goes in another.
Lots of them, OK?
Now it's always tempting to
just write down this derivative
and then just write
down the equation.
If you do that,
that's fine, but I
would recommend
that in general what
you do is you try to
write a little chart out
to keep track of what
directions things can go.
So for example, here we have
the probability of being the m,n
state.
Now there's going to
be ways of going here.
And this is going to be going
probability of being an m plus
1,n.
What I'm going to do is
I'm going to give you
just a couple minutes.
And in two minutes, I want you
to try to write down as many
of the rates, the f's
and n's that correspond
to all these transitions.
You may not be able to
get through all of them,
but if you don't try to
figure out some of them,
then you're going to
have trouble doing it
at a later date.
Do you understand what
I'm asking you to do?
So next to each one
of these arrows,
you should write something.
So I'll give you two
minutes to kind of do
your best of writing
these things down.
All right.
Why don't we reconvene,
and we'll see how we are?
So this is very similar to
what we did on Thursday.
We have to remember
that m's are the mRNAs,
and this is what
we solved before,
where it's just a long row.
Now first of all, the mRNA
distributions and the rates,
do they depend on
the protein numbers?
No.
So what that mean about,
say, this arrow as
compared to the arrow
that would be down here?
It's going to be the
same, because n does not
appear in that equation
describing mRNA.
If we had autoregulation of
some sort, then it would.
So let's go through.
All right.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to do a verbal yelling out.
OK, ready.
This arrow.
AUDIENCE: Km.
PROFESSOR: This one
here is, 3,2,1--
AUDIENCE: Km.
PROFESSOR: Km.
All right.
Ready, 3, 2, 1.
AUDIENCE: Gamma m times m.
PROFESSOR: Gamma m times m.
3, 2, 1.
AUDIENCE: Gamma
n times m plus 1.
PROFESSOR: Gamma
m times m plus 1.
Now remember that there are
more mRNA over here then there
are here, which means that
the rate of degradation
will increase.
Now coming here,
now this is talking
about the creation
and destruction
of the proteins, changes in n.
All right, this arrow here.
Ready, 3, 2, 1.
AUDIENCE: Kp times m.
PROFESSOR: It's Kp times m.
So this is the rate of creation,
going from n minus 1 to n.
That's fine.
You know, I was looking at
my notes from last year,
and I got one of these things
incorrect, so-- and then,
OK, ready.
This one here, 3, 2, 1.
Kp times m.
So here the same rate, and
should we be surprised by that?
So the number of
proteins are changing,
but here it's the
number of mRNA that
matters, because we're talking
about the rate of translation,
right?
Now this one here, 3, 2, 1.
Gamma p times n.
And here, 3, 2, 1.
AUDIENCE: Gamma
p times n plus 1.
PROFESSOR: Gamma
All right.
Perfect.
Now this is, of course, as
you can imagine, the simplest
possible kind of set
of equations that we
could have written down.
If you have other
crazy things, you
get different distributions,
if you have autoregulation
or if you have
interactions of something
with something else, or
the same thing, so forth.
But I think it's
really very useful
to kind of write this thing
down to clarify your thinking
in these problems.
And then you can fill out--
for change of probability,
you have mn.
You come here and
you just go around
and you count, take all
the arrows coming in,
and those are ways of
increasing your probability.
And ways going out are ways of
decreasing your probability.
Now in all those cases you have
to multiply these raw rates
by the probabilities of being
in all these other states.
So can you use the
master equation
to get these probabilities
if you're out of equilibrium,
out of steady state?
So that's a question.
So the master equation
useful out of steady state?
Yes.
Ready.
3, 2, 1.
All right.
So we got a fair number of--
there is some disagreement,
but yeah.
So it actually--
the answer is yes.
And that's because you can
start with any distribution
of probabilities across all
the states that you'd like.
It could be that all of the
probabilities at one state.
It could be however you like.
And the master
equation tells you
about how that
probability distribution
will change over time.
Now if you let that
run forever, then you
come to some equilibrium
steady state.
And that's a very
interesting quantity,
is the steady state distribution
of these probabilities.
But you can actually calculate
from any initial distribution
of probabilities evolving
to any later time t what
the probability would be later.
This comes to another
question here.
All right.
So let's imagine that
at time t equal to 0,
I tell you that there
are m not mRNA and P
not-- I always do this.
I don't know, somehow my
brain does not like this.
Because the P's we want
to be probabilities.
We start with m not
mRNA, n not protein.
And maybe it's a
complicated situation.
We can't calculate
this analytically.
So what we do is we
go to our computer,
and we have it solve how this
probability distribution will
evolve so that time T
equal to some time--
if we'd like we
can say this is T1.
I'll tell you, oh, the
probability of having m and n
mRNA and protein is going
to be equal to something P1.
Now the question is,
let's say I then go
and I do this simulation again.
Now I calculate some
other at time T1 again,
the probability that
you're in the m,n state.
The question is, will
you again get P1?
So this is a question mark.
And A is yes, B is no.
All right.
I'm going to give
you 15 seconds.
I think this is very
important that you understand
what the master equation is
doing and what it is not doing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm
sorry, what's that?
Right.
OK.
So I mean, this is
just-- you know,
you program in your
computer to use the master
equation to solve how
the probabilities are
going to evolve.
I'm just telling you, start
with some initial distribution.
And if you do it
once, it says, oh,
the probability
that you're going
to have m-- this time you're
going to have mRNA proteins is
going to be P1, so it's 10%.
Great.
Now I'm asking just, if you
go back and do it again,
will you again get 10%, or
is this output stochastic?
It's OK that if you're
confused by this distinction.
I think that it's easy
to get confused by,
which is why I'm doing this.
But let's just see where we are.
Ready?
3, 2, 1.
All right.
So I'd say a majority again.
We're kind of at
the 80-20, 75-25.
A majority here are
saying that, yes, you
will get the same probability.
And this is very important
that we understand
kind of where this where
the stochasticity is somehow
embedded in these
different representations
of these modelings.
The master equation is a set of
differential equations telling
you about how the
probabilities change over time
given some initial conditions.
Now we're using these
things to calculate
the evolution of
some random process,
but the probabilities themselves
evolve deterministically.
So what that means is that
although these things are
probabilities, if
you start somewhere
and you use the master
equation to solve,
you get the same thing
every time you do it.
Now this is not true for
the Gillespie simulation,
because that, you're looking
at an individual trajectory.
An individual trajectory,
then the stochasticity
is embedded in that
trajectory itself,
whereas in the master equation,
the stochasticity arises
because these are probabilities
that are calculating,
so any individual instantiation
will be probabilistic
because you are sampling from
those different probability
distributions.
Now this is, I think, a
sufficiently important point
that if there are
questions about it,
we should talk about it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you
make the simulations?
Would you essentially--
can you take
a sum over different Gillespie?
PROFESSOR: So it's
true that you can do
a sum over different Gillespie.
But we haven't yet
told you about,
what the Gillespie algorithm
is, so I can't use that.
But indeed, you can just
use a standard solver
of differential equations.
So whatever program
you use is going
to have some way of doing this.
And once you've written
down these equations,
the fact that these are actually
probabilities doesn't matter.
So those could have
been something else.
So this could be the number
of eggs, whatever, right?
So once you've
gotten the equations,
then equations just tell
you how the problems
are going to change over time.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe this
is a silly question,
but in practice, do you have
to assume all the probabilities
are 0 above some number?
PROFESSOR: Oh no, that's not at
all a silly question, because--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Right.
And yes, it's a
very good question.
So I told you this is an
infinite set of differential
equations.
But at the same time I told you
this master equation's supposed
to be useful for something,
and kind of at the face of it,
these are incompatible ideas.
And the basic answer
is that you have
to include all the
states where there
is a sort of
non-negligible probability.
We could be concrete, though.
So let's imagine that I tell
you we want to look at the mRNA
number here.
And I tell you that
OK, Km is equal to--
well, let me make sure.
Gamma m.
What are typical lifetimes
of mRNAs in bacteria again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
Order a minute.
So that means that-- let's say
this is 0.5 minutes minus 1.
To get a lifetime
of around 2 minutes.
And then let's imagine that
this is then 50 per minute.
So an mRNA is kind of
made once a minute.
There's 50 of them.
That's a lot, but whatever.
There are a few genes.
Minute.
I wanted the number
to be something.
So there's a fair rate
of mRNA production.
Now how many
equations do you think
you might need to simulate?
So we'll think about this.
First of all, does it depend
upon the initial conditions
or not?
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It does.
So be careful.
But let's say that I tell you
that we start with 50 mRNA.
The question is,
how many equations
do you think you might
have to write down?
And let's say we want to
understand this once it
gets to, say, the equilibrium.
All right.
Number of equations.
Give me a moment to come up
with some reasonable options.
Well, these are--
let's say that this
could show up on your homework.
So the question is,
how many equations
are you going to program
into your intersimulation?
And it may be-- doesn't have to
be exactly any of these number,
but order.
Do you guys understand
the question?
So we need a different
equation for each
of these probabilities.
So in principle we have--
the master equation
gives us an infinite
number of equations.
So we have d the probability
of having 0 mRNA with respect
to time.
That's going to be-- any idea
what this is going to be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So we have a minus
Km times what?
Times p0, right.
So this is because if we
start out down here at P0.
Now we have Km.
So I was just about
to violate my rule
and just write down an equation
without drawing this thing.
So it's Km times p0.
That's a way you
lose probability,
but you can also
gain probability
at a rate that goes
as gamma m times P1.
So that's how this probability
is going to change over time.
But we have a different equation
for you for p1, for p2, for p3,
for p4, all the way, in
principle, to p1,683,000,
bla bla bla, right?
So that's problematic,
because if we
have to actually in our program
code up 100,000,000 equations,
or it could be worse.
Then we're going have
trouble with our computers.
So you always have
to have some notion
of what you should be doing.
And this also highlights
that it's really important
to have some intuitive notion of
what's going on in your system
before you go and you
start programming,
because in that
case-- well, you're
likely to write down
something that's wrong.
You won't know if you
have the right answer,
and you might do something
that doesn't make any sense.
So you have to have
some notion of what
the system should look
like before you even
start coding it.
My question is, how
many of these equations
should we simulate?
OK.
Let's just see where we are.
Ready.
3, 2, 1.
OK.
So I'd say that we
have, it's basically
between C and D. Yeah.
I would say some people are
maybe more careful than I am.
Can one of the Ds maybe
defend why they're saying D?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The mean is 100,
and when you say-- I mean,
I think that whatever
you're thinking is correct,
but I think that the words
are a little dangerous.
And why am I concerned
about-- you said--
is the mean 100 for all time?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
and steady state.
PROFESSOR: And steady state.
Right.
I think that was the-- for long
times, the mean number of mRNA
will, indeed, be 100.
So the mean number
of m, in this case,
will be Km divided
by gamma m, which
is going to be equal
to 50 divided by that.
That gets us 100.
Now will it be exactly 100?
No.
It's going to be 100
plus or minus what?
Plus or minus 10.
Right.
Because this distribution
at steady state is what?
AUDIENCE: It's Poisson.
PROFESSOR: It's Poisson.
What's the variance of
a Poisson distribution?
It's equal to the mean.
So for Poisson, the variance
is equal to the mean.
Variance is the square of
the standard deviation,
which means that this is
going to be plus or minus 10.
That's kind of the typical
width of the distribution.
So what it means is
that at equilibrium,
we're going to be at 100 and
it's going to kind of look
like this.
So this might be 2 sigma,
so this could be 20.
But each of these is 10.
So if you want to
capture this, you
might want to go
out to a few sigma.
So let's say you want
to go out to 3 sigma,
then you might want to
get out to 130 maybe.
So then, if you want
to be more careful
you go out to 140 or 150.
But this thing is going
to decay exponentially,
so you don't need
to go up TO 1,000,
because the probability's
going to be 0 0 0.
Certain once you're at 200 you
don't have to worry about it.
But of course, you have to
remember the initial condition
we started at 50.
So we started at this point,
which means we definitely
have to include that equation.
Otherwise we're in trouble.
Now how much do we have
to go to below 50 Any--
AUDIENCE: My guess would be
that it would be not much
more than the [? few ?] times
5, because if it were already
at equilibrium that
would be the mean.
But it's not, and
so the driving force
is still going to push
it back to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So it's going to
be a bias random
walk here, where it's
going to be sort of maybe
twice as likely at each step to
be moving right as to be moving
left.
That means it could
very well go to 49, 48.
But it's not really going
to go below 40, say.
Of course you have to
quantify these things
if you want to be careful.
But certainly I would say going
from, I don't know, 35 to 135
would be fine with me.
You would get full credit
on your problem set.
So we'll say-- I'm going to
make this up-- from 35 to 135,
134 just so it could
be 100 equations.
So I'd say I'd be fine
with 100 equations.
So you would simulate the
change in the probabilities
of P35 to P134, for example.
So although in principle,
the master equation
specifies how the probabilities
for an infinite number
of equations are
going to change,
you only need to simulate
a finite number of them
depending upon the
dynamics of your system.
Yes.
Thank you for the question,
because it's a very important
practical thing.
AUDIENCE: So in
practice, you don't
know what the solution is,
which is sort of why you would
[INAUDIBLE].
Do you explain your range and
see if the solution changes?
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, in this case,
it's a little bit cheating
because we already kind of knew
the answer.
We didn't know exactly
how the time dependence
was going to go.
How is it that the mean is going
to change over time on average?
Exponentially, right?
So on average you
will start at 50.
You exponentially relax to 100.
But in many cases, we don't
know so much about the system.
And I'd say that what,
in general, you can do
is, you have to always specify
a finite number of equations.
But then what you can do
is, you can put in, like,
reflecting boundary
conditions or so on the end,
so you don't allow
probability to escape.
But then what you can do is
you can run the simulation,
and if you have some
reasonable probability to any
of your boundaries, then
you know you're in trouble
and you have to
extend it from there.
So you can look to
say, oh, is it above 10
to the minus 3 or 4, whatever.
And then if it is, then you
know you have to go further.
Any other questions about
how-- you're actually
going to be doing
simulations of this, so these
are relevant questions for you.
All right.
So that's the master equation.
But I'd say the key,
key thing to remember
is that it tells
you how to calculate
the deterministic evolution of
the probability of these states
given some potentially
complicated set
of interactions.
Now, a rather orthogonal
view to the master equation
is to use the
Gillespie algorithm,
or in general, to do direct
stochastic simulations
of individual trajectories.
Yeah.
Question before we go.
AUDIENCE: So if we just set
it to 0, the probabilities
outside the range
we think we need,
would we be losing probability?
PROFESSOR: So the question
is whether we're somehow
losing probability.
So what I was proposing
before is that you always
want probabilities to sum to 1.
Otherwise it's not
our probability
and the mathematicians
get upset.
And the key thing
there is that you
want to start with-- you have
to include all the states that
have probability
at the beginning.
So in that sense, you're
given an initial distribution,
and you have to include
all those states.
Otherwise you're definitely
going to do something funny.
You start out with a normalized
probability distribution.
And then I guess
what I was proposing
is that you have a finite
number of equations,
but you don't let
the probability leave
or come in from those ends.
And if you do that,
then you will always
have a normalized
probability distribution.
Of course, at the
ends you've kind of
violated the actual
equations, and that's
why you have to
make sure that you
don't have significant
probability at any
of your boundaries.
Does that answer?
Not quite?
AUDIENCE: Because I'm
wondering if [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So I was not
suggesting that you set
the probabilities equal to 0.
I was suggesting that you
do what's kind of like what
the equations actually here,
which is that you don't
allow any probability to leave.
There's no probably
flux on this edge.
So for example, out at P134,
I would just say, OK, well,
here's the probability
that you have 134 mRNA.
And in principle there
are these two arrows,
but you can just
get rid of them.
So now any probability that
enters here can only come back.
And I've somehow
violated my equations.
But if P134 is essentially
0, then it doesn't matter.
So instead of looking at these
probabilities evolve kind of as
a whole, we can instead look at
individual trajectories, right?
So the idea here is that if
we start with the situation--
actually, we can
take this thing here.
So we know that at steady
state it's going to be 100.
Starts out at 50.
And in this case, with the
master equation you say,
OK, well, you start out with
all the probability right here.
So you have kind of a
delta function at 50.
But then what happens is
this thing kind of evolves,
and over time this
thing kind of spreads
until you have
something that looks
like this, where you have a
Poisson distribution centered
around 100.
And this Poisson
distribution's going
to be very close to a
Gaussian, because you
have a significant number.
So the master equation tells
you how this probability
distribution evolves.
Now this is the number m and
this is kind of the frequency
that you observe it.
So we can also
kind of flip things
so we instead plot the
number m on the y-axis.
And we already said the
deterministic equations
will look like this.
And the characteristic time
scale for this is what?
1 over mm, right?
So this thing relaxes
to the equilibrium,
time scale determined by the
degradation time of the mRNA.
So these are things
that should be really--
you want to be kind of
drilled into your head,
and I'm trying to drill,
so you'll hear them again
and again.
Now the master equation, indeed,
since everything's linear here,
the expectation value over
the probability distributions
actually does behave like this.
So the mean of the distributions
as a function of time
look like that.
And in some ways, if
we were to plot this,
we would say, OK, well,
first of all it's all here.
Then it kind of looks like this.
So this is somehow how those
probability distributions are
kind of expanding over time.
Now for an individual
trajectories,
if we run a bunch of
stochastic simulations,
we'll get something that
on average looks like this,
but it might look like this.
A different one might
look like this, and so on,
although they shouldn't
converge there
because that's not consistent.
And if you did a histogram
at all those different times
of the individual
stochastic trajectories,
you should recover the
probability distribution
that you got for
the master equation.
So this is a powerful
way just to make sure
that, for example, your
simulations are working,
that you can check to make
sure that everything behaves
in a consistent way.
Now there's a major
question, though,
of how is it that
you should generate
these stochastic trajectories?
And the sort of most
straightforward thing to do
is to just divide up time into
a bunch of little delta t's,
and just ask whether
anything happened.
So let me--
So what we want to do is we
want to imagine we have maybe
m chemical species.
So now these are
different m's and n's.
Be careful.
m chemical species, they could
be anything, could be proteins,
they could be small
molecules, something.
And there are n
possible reactions.
And indeed, in some
cases people want
to study the stochastic
dynamics of large networks.
So you could have
50 chemical species
and 300 different reactions.
So this could be
rather complicated.
And these m chemical species
have, we'll say, numbers
or if you'd like, in some cases
it could be concentrations, Xi,
so then the whole thing can
be described as some vector X.
And the question is, how
should we assimilate this?
The so-called, what we often
call the naive protocol--
and this is indeed what
I did in graduate school
because nobody told me that
I wasn't supposed to do it--
is that you divide time into
little time segments delta t.
Small delta t.
And you just do
this over and over.
And for each delta t you
ask, did anything happen?
If it did, then you update.
If not, you keep on going.
Now the problem with
this approach-- well,
what is the problem
with this approach?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Time is continuous.
So one problem is that, well,
you don't like discrete time.
That's understandable.
But I'm going to say, well, you
know, the details-- a delta t
may be small, so
you won't notice.
I'm saying, if I said
delta t being small,
then I'm going to claim that
you're not going to notice that
I've--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: But then the
simulation is slow, right?
So there's a fundamental
trade-off here.
And in particular, the
problem with this protocol
is that for it to
behave reasonably,
delta t has to be very small.
And what do I mean by
very small, though?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
For this to work,
delta t has to be
such that unlikely for
anything to happen.
But this is already a
problem, because that
means that we're doing
a lot of simulations,
and then just
nothing's happening.
How do we figure out
what that probability is?
So in particular, we
can ask about-- well,
given possible reactions,
we'll say with rates rs of i.
So the probability that the i'th
reaction occurs is equal to r i
times delta t for small delta t,
because each of these reactions
will occur kind of at a rate--
they're going to be exponential
distributions of the
times for them to occur.
This is a Poisson process
because it's random.
Now what we want to know is
the probability that nothing
is going to happen
because that's how we're
going to have set delta t.
Well, what we can
imagine is, then
we say, well, what's the
probability that is, say,
not reaction 1 and
not 2 and dot dot dot.
OK.
Well, and this is in
some time delta t.
Well, actually, we know that
if the fundamental process just
looks like this,
then we're going
to get exponential
distributions for each of those.
So we end up with e
to the r1, and indeed,
once we write an exponential,
we don't have to write delta t.
This is just some time t.
For this to be true requires
a delta t is very small.
But if we want to
just ask, what's
the probability that reaction
1 has not happened in some time
t, this actually is,
indeed, precisely equal
to e to the r1t.
Yeah, details.
And this is e to the minus
r2t dot dot dot minus.
And we go up to n, r to the nt,
because each of those chemical
reactions are going to be
exponentially distributed
in terms of how long you have
to wait for them to happen.
And what's neat about
this is that this means
that if you just ask
about the probability
distribution for all of them
combined by saying that none
of them have happened,
this is actually
just equal to the
exponent of minus--
now we might pull the t out
and we just sum over ri.
So this is actually, somehow,
a little bit surprising,
which is that each of
those chemical reactions
occur, and they're occurring
at different rates.
Some of them might be fast,
some of them might be slow.
The ri's can be different
by orders of magnitude.
But still, over these hundreds
of chemical reactions,
if the only thing
you want to know
is, oh, what's the
probability that none of them
have happened,
that is also going
to end up-- that's going
to decay exponentially.
And this actually tells us
something very interesting,
which is that if we want to
know the distribution of times
for the first thing
to happen, that's
also going to be
exponentially distributed.
And it's just
exponentially distributed
with a rate that is given
by the sum of these rates.
Now that's the
basic insight behind
this GIllespie algorithm, where
instead of dividing things up
into a bunch of little times
delta t, instead what you do
is you ask, how long am
I going to have to wait
before the first thing happens?
And you just sample from an
exponential with this rate
r that is the sum of the rates.
Maybe it's even worth
saying that, OK,
so there's the naive
algorithm where you just
divide a bunch of delta t's,
you just take a little steps,
you say, OK, nothing, nothing,
nothing, nothing, and then
eventually something
happens, and then
you update, you keep on going.
There's the somewhat less naive
algorithm, which is exact,
so it's not the same
concerns, the j hat which
is that you could just sample
from n different exponentials,
each with their
own rates, and then
just take the minimum
of them and say, OK,
that's the that happened first,
and then update from that.
And that's an exact algorithm.
But the problem is that you
have to sample from possibly
many different exponentials.
And that's not a
disaster, but again, it's
computationally slow.
So the Gillespie algorithm
removes the requirement
to from those n exponentials,
because instead what you
do is you just say, the
numbers, or the concentrations,
give all of the ri,
give you all the rates.
And then what you
do is you sample
from an exponential
with rate r, which
is the sum over all the ri.
That tells you, when is the
first reaction going to occur.
And then what you do is you ask,
well, which reaction did occur?
Because you actually
don't know that yet.
And there, it's just the
probabilities of each of them.
So the probabilities
Pi is just going
to be the ri divided by the
sum over the ri, so this big R.
So it may be that you had 300
possible chemical reactions,
but you only have to
do two things here.
And they're both kind
of simple, right?
You sample from one
exponential, gives you
how long you had to wait
for something to happen.
And then you just sample from
another simple probability
thing here that just
tells you which of the n
possible chemical reactions
was it that actually occurred.
And of course, the
chemical reactions
that were occurring
at a faster rate
have a higher probability
of being chosen.
So this actually is an
exact procedure in the sense
that there's no digitization of
time or anything of the sort.
So this actually is
computationally efficient
and is exact, assuming that
your description of the chemical
reactions was accurate
to begin with.
So then what we do
is we update time.
This is in some ways--
when you do computations,
when you actually do
simulations-- this is maybe
the annoying part about the
Gillespie algorithm, which
is that now your times
are not equally spaced,
and so then you
just have to make
sure you remember that, you
don't plot something that's
incorrect.
Because your times are going
to hop at different time
intervals.
But that's doable.
You have to update
your time and you
have to update your abundances.
And then what you do is repeat.
I think the notes kind of allude
to this Gillespie algorithm
but are not quite explicit
about what you actually
do to go through this process.
For the simulations that you're
going to do in this class,
I would say that you don't
get the full benefits
of the Gillespie in the
sense that you're not
going to be simulating hundreds
of differential equations
with hundreds of
different things.
But it's in those
complicated models
that you really have to do this
kind of Gillespie approach,
as compared to even this
somewhat better model, which is
you sample from the
different exponentials.
Are there any questions
about why this might work,
why you might want to do it?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What do you mean
by sample the exponentials?
PROFESSOR: Right.
What I mean is that you
go to Matlab and you say,
random-- I'm sort of
serious, but-- sorry,
I'm trying to get
a new-- All right.
So you the exponential.
So it's a probability
distribution.
So this is the probability is
a function of time and then t.
And it's going to look
something like this.
This thing is going to be some--
given that, in general, it's
going to be the probability t is
going to be e to the minus rt.
And then do I put r here
or do I put 1 over r?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Is it 1 over r?
Well, what should be the units
of a probability distribution?
1 over time, in this case.
It's 1 over whatever's
on this x-axis,
because if you want to get
the actual, honest to goodness
probability-- so if you want
the probability that t is,
say, between t1 and
t1 plus delta t.
If you want an
actual probability,
then this thing is equal to
the probability density at t1,
in this case, times delta t.
So that means thing has
to have a 1 over time,
and that gives us r here.
So this is probability
density, and what
I'm saying is that when I say
sample from this probability
distribution, what it means is
that it's like rolling a die,
but that it's a biased
die because it's
continuous thing over the time.
But just like when you have a
six-sided die and I say, OK,
sample from the die,
you're playing Monopoly,
you throw the die and
you get 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
And you do that
over and over again.
Same thing here.
You kind of roll the die
and see what happens.
And indeed, you're going to get
some practice with probability
distributions on the
homework that you're
doing right now because you're
asked to demonstrate that you
can sample from a uniform
distribution, which something
that's just equally probable
across the unit line,
and do a transformation and get
an exponential distribution.
And it used to be that
everybody knew all these tricks
because you had to
kind of know them
in order to do computation.
But now, Matlab, or
whatever program you use,
they know all the
tricks, so you just
ask it to sample from an
exponential with this property
and it does it for you.
But you still need to
know what it's doing.
So just to be clear, what
is the most likely time
that you're going to get
out from the exponential?
0.
It has a peak here but
the mean is over here.
Any other questions about how
the Gillespie algorithm works?
Can somebody tell me how
a protein burst arises?
So we had this original
question about whether there
were protein bursts
in that model
that I wrote down, where we
just had m dot is equal to--
Now what we said was that the
master equation would not--
the protein burst
would somehow be
there are but you
would never see them,
or somehow the protein burst
would influence how the mean
and everything have evolved,
but you wouldn't actually
see any big jumps.
But then we said, oh, but if
you did a stochastic simulation,
you would.
So the claim here is that
the Gillespie algorithm,
what I've just told you here,
will lead to protein bursts.
When I make that statement,
what is it that I actually mean?
If we do a Gillespie
of this, will the-- OK,
let's just hold on.
Let me do a quick vote.
Will we have cases where
delta n is greater than 1?
If I go through this process,
if I'm using the Gillespie
and I'm tracking how mRNA and
protein number are changing
over time, will I get these
things, protein bursts,
where delta n is larger than
1 in one of these time cycles?
Ready?
3, 2, 1.
So most of the group is saying
that it's going to be no.
But again, it's mixed.
So can somebody say
why we don't get--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] It
seems like the structure
of the simulation is to
make sure [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah.
So the simulation
as written-- you
could imagine some sort of
phenomenological version
of this where you allowed,
actually, for protein bursts.
But as kind of specified
is that we ask,
what's the time for
one thing to happen?
But the claim somehow is,
OK, well, we can still
get protein bursts from this.
And how does that happen?
AUDIENCE: You can have the
rate for something happening
increase suddenly, and that
would happen if we go from m
equals 0 to m equals 1--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, for example,
if we didn't have an mRNA before
and we got an mRNA.
What it means that
if you look at n
as a function of time
during one of these protein
bursts-- before, I was drawing
it just hopping up, but really,
in the context of
the Gillespie, it
would be that it would hop, hop.
So there would be
little time jumps.
So this is a protein
burst, but it's really
before this mRNA is
degraded, you get 1, 1, 1, 1.
So each of these
as is delta n of 1.
So this is whatever, 6, 7.
And then what can happen is
that we get the mRNA degraded.
And so then we're going
to get a slower thing
where it-- looks like that.
So the Gillespie, everything
is being created and destroyed
in units of 1.
But it could be that the
time interval over this burst
is just very short, so then
it goes up very quickly,
but then it's slower to go away.
So what I want to do in
just the last 15 minutes
is talk a bit about the
Fokker-Planck approximation.
I would say that all these
different approaches are
useful to varying degrees
in terms of actually doing
simulations, doing
analytic calculations,
getting intuition.
And the Fokker-Planck
approach, I'd say it's
more or less useful
for different people
depending on what you're doing.
So the basic idea,
as kind of you
answered in the
pre-class reading,
is that in cases where
n is large enough
that you don't
feel like you need
to take into account
the discrete nature
of the molecules,
yet at the same time
it's not so large
that you can totally
ignore the fluctuations, then
the Fokker-Planck approach
is nice because it allows you
to get some sense of what's
going on without all of the
crazy details of, for example,
the master equation.
And then it also,
because of this idea
of an effective
potential, it allows
you to bring all the intuition
from that into your study
of these gene circuits.
Now I'm not going to go
through the whole derivation,
but if you have
questions about that,
please come up
after class and I'm
happy to go through it with
you, because it's sort of fun.
But the notes do go over it.
I think that's what's perhaps
useful to just remind ourselves
of is how it maybe leads to
a Gaussian with some width
depending upon the shapes of the
production degradation curves.
So the basic notion
here is that, depending
on the f's and g's, the
production degradation terms,
we get different shaped
effective potentials.
So in general we
have something that
looks like-- we have some
n dot, there's some fn,
and then there's a minus gn.
So for example, for something
that is just simple expression,
in the case of--
let's just imagine now
that there is-- if you want we
can say it's a protein where
it's just some k minus gamma n.
Or if you'd like, we could
say, oh, this is mRNA number.
But something that's just
simple production, and then
first order degradation.
The question is, how do
we go about understanding
this in the context of the
Fokker-Planck approximation?
And it turns out
that you can write it
in what is essentially a
diffusion equation where
you have some probability
flux that's moving around.
And within that
realm, you can write
that the probability
distribution of the number
is going to be something
that-- so there's
going to be some constant.
There's f plus g.
And these are both
functions of n.
And then you have e to
the minus [INAUDIBLE]
So the idea here is
that this behaves
as some effective potential.
Of course, it's not quite
true because f and g also
are functions of n,
they're are not in here.
But this is the dominant
term because it's
in the exponential.
And here phi n is
defined as the following.
So it's minus this integral
over n of the f minus g
and f plus g dn that we
integrate over n prime.
And we're going to
kind of go through what
some of these different
f's and g's might
look like to try to get a
sense of why this happened.
It is worth mentioning
that you can
do this for any f and g when
it's just in one dimension,
so you just have n.
Once you have it
in two dimensions,
so once you actually
have mRNA and protein,
for example, you're
not guaranteed
to to be able to write it
as an effective potential.
Although I guess if you're
willing to invoke a vector
potential, then maybe you can.
But in terms of just
a simple potential,
then you can do it one
dimension, but not necessarily
in more.
And I think that, in general,
our intuition is not as useful
when you have the equivalent
of magnetic fields and so forth
here anyway.
What I want to do is
just try to understand
why this thing looks the way it
does for this simple regulation
case.
And then we're going to ask if
we change one thing or another,
how does it affect the
resulting variance.
So for unregulated
expression, such as here,
if we look at the production and
degradation as a function of n,
fn is just some constant
k, whereas gn is
a line that goes up as gamma n.
Now in this situation, if you
do this integral-- and really,
what you can imagine is what
this integral looks like right
around that steady
state, because that's
kind of what we want to know,
if we want to something about,
for example, the width
of a distribution.
Well, there's going
to b e two terms.
In the numerator
there's an f minus g.
In the denominator
there's an f plus g.
Now f minus g is
actually equal to 0 right
at that steady
state, and that's why
it's a steady state, because
production and degradation are
equal.
Now as you go away from
that location, what you're
doing is you're integrating
the difference between the f
and the g.
And you can see that around
here these things are
separating kind of-- well,
everything's a line here.
And indeed, even if f
and g were not linear,
close to that steady state
they would be linear.
What we can see is that
as you're integrating,
you're integrating
across something
that is growing linearly.
That's what gives
you a quadratic.
And that's why this
effect of potential
ends up behaving as if
you're in a quadratic trap.
Now I encourage you to go
ahead and do that integral
at some point.
I was planning on
doing it for you today,
but we are running out of time.
Once again, I'm happy to
do it, just after class.
And indeed, what you can see is
that because you're integrating
across here, you end up
getting a quadratic increase
in the effective potential.
And if you look at what the
variance of that thing is,
you indeed find that the
variance is equal to the mean
here.
So what I want to ask
in terms of trying
to get intuition
is, what happens
if we pull these curves down?
So in particular,
let's imagine that we
have a situation
where-- I'm going
to re-parameterize
things, so again, we're
kind of keeping the number
of the equilibrium constant.
But now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to have an fn
that looks like this,
and gn looks like-- now gn is
going to be some 1/2 of lambda,
and this fn is equal to
k minus 1/2 of gamma n.
Now the question is,
in this situation,
what will be the
variance over the mean?
Well, first of all, the
variance over the mean
here was equal to what?
Although should we do vote?
Here are going to
be some options.
Question is variance over
the mean in this situation.
I'm worried that this
is not going to work,
but let's just see where are.
Ready, 3, 2, 1.
All right.
So I'd say that at
least broadly, people
are agreeing that the
variance over the mean
here is equal to 1.
And again, this is the
situation that we've
analyzed many times, which
is that in this situation
we get a poisson,
where the poisson only
has one free parameter, and
that parameter specifies
both the mean and the variance.
So for a poisson, the
variance of the mean
is indeed equal to 1.
So the Fokker-Planck
approximation actually
accurately recapitulates that.
Now the question is, what will
the variance over the mean
be in the situation that
I've just drawn here?
So I'm going to
give you a minute
to try to think about
what this means.
And there are multiple
ways of figuring it out.
You can look at,
maybe, the integral.
You can think about the
biological intuition
to make at least a guess
of of what it should do.
The question is,
if the production
rate and the degradation
rate look like this,
what does that mean for
the variance over the mean?
So I'll give you a minute
to kind of play with it.
Why don't we go
ahead and vote, just
so I can get a sense
of where we are?
And also, it's OK if you
can't actually figure this out
or you're confused.
But go ahead and make
your best guess anyways,
because it's also
useful if you can guess
kind of the direction it'll go,
even if you can't figure out
its magnitude.
So let's vote.
Ready, 3, 2, 1.
OK.
So it's a mixture now,
I'd say, of A, B, C, Ds.
Yeah, I think this is, I
think, hard and confusing.
I maybe won't have-- all right.
I'll maybe say something.
It may be that talking to each
other won't help that much.
OK, so in this case,
what's relevant
is both the f minus
g and the f plus g.
And it turns out that f minus g
actually behaves the same way,
because at the fixed point,
or at the equilibrium,
it starts at 0 and then it
actually grows in the same way
as you go away from it.
The difference is the f plus
g, where that's very much not
equal to 0.
And f plus g at the
equilibrium, this f plus g
here is around 2k, whereas f
plus g over here is around 1k.
What that means is
that in both cases
you have a quadratic potential.
But here the quadratic potential
actually ends up being steeper.
So if this were
unregulated, then over here
we still get a quadratic,
but it's with steeper walls.
So actually here, this,
the variance over the mean,
ends up being 1/2.
It's useful to go ahead and
just play with these equations
to see why that happens.
And I think that's a nice
way to think about this
is, in this limit, where we
pull this crossing point all
the way down to 0,
now we have something
that looks kind of like this.
So very, very low
rate of degradation.
But then also the
production rate
essentially goes to 0
when we're at this point.
So we could still
parameterize as k over gamma
if we want, with some--
but we could just
think about this as being
at 100 of these mRNAs, say.
But then we're changing the
production degradation rate.
And the variance
over the mean here--
does anybody have a
guess of where that goes?
In this case it
actually goes to 0.
And this is an interesting
situation, because really,
in the limit where
there's no degradation,
and it's all at the
production side, what
it's saying is that you produce,
you produce, you produce,
until you get to this
number, which might be 100,
and then you simply
stop doing anything.
You're not degrading,
you're not producing.
In that case all the cells will
have exactly 100, maybe, mRNA.
And what the Fokker-Planck
kind of formalism
tells you is that just because
production and degradation
rates are equal, f
minus g is equal to 0,
doesn't mean that--
that tells you
that that's the equilibrium,
but it doesn't tell you
how much spread there's going
to be around the equilibrium.
If f and g are each larger,
that leads to a larger spread
because there's more randomness,
whereas here, f and g are
both essentially
0 at that point.
What that means is
that you kind of just
pile up right at
that precise value.
We are out of time, so
I think we should quit.
But I am available
for the next half hour
if anybody has any questions.
Thanks.